ça a parlé de la façon dont on nous
montre l'archéologie dans les médias
dans les documentaires et dans les
vidéos youtube également avant de
démarrer j'ai besoin de vous on va faire
un petit sondage qui parmi vous vous
allez levez la main a voulu faire un
jour le métier d'archéologue ou de
paléontologues ouais ça fait un paquet
de monde
est ce que vous savez pourquoi pourquoi
ce métier c'est moi qui réponds c'est
moi qui réponds donc c'est un métier qui
passionne et dont on vous parle souvent
à la télé notamment
ok donc comme vous l'avez dit ça peut
être pour le kotéba découverte découvrir
des choses mystérieuses qui est
mystérieux c'est ce qu'on n'a pas
identifiés ça peut être à la suite d'un
film donc il ya forcément des amateurs
d'indiana jones ici ouais rien ouais bah
ça va piquer un petit peu un moment
donné je suis désolé et souvent c'est à
la suite de docu qu'on voit à la télé
donc cette conférence que je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi vous avez voulu faire
ce métier puis brisé au passage vous
dernier rêve d'enfance alors commençons
par les documentaires documentaire vidéo
youtube qui traite de
deux sites archéologiques et où là c'est
pas bon et qui surf
la plupart du temps sur la vague du
mystère et de l'énigme en archéologie
alors saluons quasiment jamais on vous
montre des images toujours accompagné
d'une musique de film à suspense d'une
musique de film dramatique
moi j'ai déjà vu un plan sur des
latrines des latrines si les chiottes à
rome avec une musique de film à suspense
allez savoir ce qu'il allait bien
pouvoir se passer d'exceptionnel là
dedans et donc après une introduction de
palpitant non tu devais toujours le
documentaire qui se propose alors
charitablement de vous faire entrer vous
chanceux téléspectateurs dans les
vestiges d'une cité antique que vous
imaginez donc rempli de trésors
bon ça c'est la télé à les entendre on
peut trouver le bonheur sur terre et un
qu'en achetant des lessives et dans ce
milieu
dans ce marketing audiovisuel
l'archéologie elle a une place à part
pas parce que c'est ma spécialité que ça
me tient à coeur mais parce que
l'archéologie c'est une science et
vendre de la science comme on vend la
lessive ça pose problème surtout quand
on raconte n'importe quoi parce que là
moi je vais vous expliquer toutes les
bêtises qu'on vous raconte à longueur de
temps sur le passé de l'humanité sous
prétexte de vouloir faire de l'audience
et donc pour sabah je suis obligé de
choisir des exemples emblématiques des
choses que vous ayez forcément vu un
jour sur vos écrans donc on va parler
des pyramides gerwig d'égypte qui on ira
un petit peu au mexique et on va aussi
parler de la lienne théorie tauriac les
extraterrestres vous êtes tous déjà vu
un truc sur les extraterrestres
c'est bon vous allez image en tête ok
alors on va commencer avec l'exemple
phare quand on pense archéologie c'est
les pyramides flingues des gîtes ou
plutôt les mystères de la construction
des pyramides
alors que les choses quelque chose soit
claire ya pas de mystère concernant la
construction des pyramides
on la connaît bien et ce même barbant au
possible en fait une pyramide c'est très
très logique
si vous voulez construire très large et
très haut mais que vous n'avez pas les
moyens techniques de lier les pierres
avec du ciment
avec du mortier et bien la forme
pyramidale donc une base très large qui
supporte une élévation élevé qui sera
dit statines une pyramide
eh bien c'est la forme la plus stable ça
n'importe quel architecte pourra vous le
dire cette forme elle est tellement
stable tellement pratique et facile à
mettre en oeuvre
et bien qu'elle a été découverte et
appliquée par plusieurs civilisations à
différents moments de l'histoire
l'humanité
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous avez
des pyramides un petit peu partout dans
le monde
le truc c'est que dans les documentaires
et les vidéos youtube on vous fait
croire que la pyramide
enfin que toutes les pyramides du monde
ont une origine égyptienne comme si les
égyptiens
il avait un peu breveté la pyramide puis
qu'il avait exporté à l'international et
donc à cette idée de diffusion retenez
bien ce mot parce qu'on en reparle et
après que les égyptiens de l'antiquité
aurait diffusé les plans des pyramides
et petit truc en plus qui les aurait
volontairement aligné
vous avez sans doute vu déjà des cartes
du monde on vous met un rouge des
pierres l'hymne des petits triangles et
puis on vous le traces des traits entre
ces points alors déjà deux mots au sujet
de l'alignement des sites alors on
reprend cette carte avec ces fameux
points indique les points se sont bas
donc des pyramides vous en mettez un au
caire les permis de lise et puis un
autre au mexique
qu'importe chichen itza thibault cas
n'importe fait un très bien il pourrait
bien les bouger comme vous voulez pour
est toujours lié les points entre eux et
ça ça marche pour tous pas seulement
pour les pyramides
vous pouvez faire un trait entre guise
et et stonehenge puis un mois il ya
moyen que sur le trajet independent très
vous tombiez sur un site anciens donc la
limande l'alignement des sites assez
complètement une coïncidence
bon l'autre truc maintenant cette idée
de diffusion c'est plus complexe mais
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant si on
pense que les pyramides sont originaires
tous les permis du monde sont d'origine
égyptienne notamment celle du mexique sa
loupe jamais et quand même un moment où
donc des pharaons de l'es20 des
égyptiens de l'époque pharaonique ont dû
faire le trajet egypte mexique
les égyptiens de l'époque pharaonique
c'est donc en gros 4500 4500 ans ils ont
dû donc abandonné traverser l'atlantique
les 4500 ans pour des égyptiens
traverser l'atlantique ça veut dire à la
rame sans voile avec des connaissances
de la navigation hauturière donc la
navigation en haute mer un très solide
et surtout ça faudra m'expliquer pagayer
pendant des milliers de kilomètres à
contre-courant parce que quand vous
faites le trajet de 2 en ce sens là
egypte amérique vous avez un bon courant
dans la face un camion de se choper des
craintes quand même hein alors moi quand
je le dis comme ça là vous devez vous
dire bah oui c'est complètement stupide
personne peut penser ça truc c'est que
ses thèses
elles sont très très tenace elles sont
notamment soutenus par les afro
centriste alors c'est le point
vocabulaire de la conférence ça va aller
c'est pas très long
les afro centriste peut-être que vous
connaissez le terme eurocentrisme
l'eurocentrisme c'est le fait de centrer
les faits de l'histoire sur l'europe
bon bah là
même chose pour l'afrique dans les
années 50 les africains ils ont voulu
retrouver une place centrale dans
l'histoire mondiale et ils ont donc créé
cette doctrine qu'on appelle
l'afrocentrisme et qui essaye de faire
de l'afrique le berceau de toutes les
civilisations et qui donc dit que les
civilisations mésoaméricaine en gros les
incas les mayas et les aztèques ont hâte
de retrouver les olmèques ils auraient
une origine égyptienne
donc en fait là les pieds ravine faut
bien comprendre que c'est qu'un prétexte
pour nourrir une idéologie ce soit celle
d eurocentrisme procède et afro
centriste et ses idéologies on peut les
résumer par les questions suivantes à
qui appartient l'egypte antique
si tant est qu'elles appartiennent à
quelqu'un et à qui appartient la
découverte de l'amérique donc les
documentaires les vidéos qui vous fondez
créé des associations de pensée entre
des sites archéologiques qui n'ont
aucune correspondance géographique
aucune correspondance chronologique font
ce qu'on appelle du diffusio nisme et ça
c'est absolument pas approuvé par la
science donc soyez vigilents prochaine
fois que vous voyez des on vous trace
des traits crier l'aube théorie donc
j'aimerais vous parler est une théorie
qui considèrent au contraire que vous
tous là moi y compris d'ailleurs vous
êtes des gros nazes des gros gros nullos
vous ne savez pas aligner trois cahiers
cette théorie est très en vogue il a
encore de beaux jours devant elle
c'est la lienne théorie théorique les
extraterrestres ça fonctionne là dessus
c'est de dire nous sommes des incapables
et nous avons besoin de sauveur ses
sauveurs ce sont des extraterrestres qui
donc nous ont aidés à construire les
monuments authentiques ils ont été
depuis un mois je les ai jamais vus ils
nous aident pas à construire la future
tour trump ou je ne sais quoi et ça va
et donc bas cette théorie la plupart du
temps on les retrouve dans les films de
fiction alors par exemple on peut dire
on peut citer indiana jones 4
celui que les crânes de cristal que je
me suis tapé spécialement pour la
conférence pour vous montrer que super
violence est aujourd'hui bon bah
spielberg à la fin il peut pas
s'empêcher de sortir des extraterrestres
pourquoi parce que son scénario il part
un peu dans tous les sens et qu'il faut
trouver une solution pour régler à pour
clôturer le film et si vous voulez
d'aller les extraterrestres c'est le
summum du mystère et en même temps c'est
la solution qui a réponse à tout
la lienne théorie c'est la solution la
plus feignante qu'ils soient au moins
les autres elles ont le mérite de faire
intervenir la créativité l'imagination
humaine celle ci s convoque elles se
contentent pardon simplement de
convoquer une force supérieure vaguement
omnipotente dans un but et eric qu'on
est pas bien saisi
voilà moi je me suis demandée vie
pourquoi les aliens nous ont aidés avant
d'insister puisqu'ils sont barrées
pourquoi on a arrêté la collaboration en
fait le monument antique
ce sont les objets parfait pour
supporter une alien théorie tout
simplement parce que les témoins de
cette époque sont norme serait plus
compliqué de
nous faire gober ça aujourd'hui et puis
en plus on serait pas content il
appliquerait notre travail bon j'ai pas
essayé de démonter toutes les théories
fumeuses sur les aliens avec des
arguments rationnels lorsque ce serait
absurde et que ça prendrait beaucoup
trop de temps en fait faut plutôt
s'intéresser à ce qu'il ya derrière la
passion pour le mystère ce qui fait qu
on est attiré par des hypothèses aussi
tiré par les cheveux et en fait alors là
c'est vraiment le de l'histoire il ya
toujours l'idée sous jacente d'un
complot les universitaires du monde
entier cacher la vérité aux banques
éthiques qui complètement paradoxal
parce que les scientifiques sont
justement des gens qui consacrent leur
vie à rendre public ce qui était mon
fouillis mais il ya des vraies raisons
au fait qu'on arrive à remettre en cause
les écrits scientifiques
j'en ai trouvé 2 3 je vais vous les
donner d'abord ça peut être une
motivation politique
ces cadres l'afrocentrisme
l'afrocentrisme à l'origine c'est une
revendication de l'afrique pour
retrouver une place centrale au sein de
l'histoire
donc c'est une initiative tout à fait
louable mais qu'elle était complètement
reprises à l'excès ça peut être une
motivation religieuse
il ya beaucoup de documentaires quand
c'est le cas à part dans ses cales
d'allende et là beaucoup de
documentaires qui sont donc diffusés sur
des chaînes de télé peu scrupuleuses qui
sont financés par des sectes
évangélistes chrétiens est en fait
depuis la sphère roswell aux états unis
c'est en 47 le groupe les ovnis ça un
succès fou il succès vous ça veut dire
beaucoup de pognon à la clé à part les
évangélistes chrétiens vous avez la
nation of islam
vous avez peut-être entendu déjà parlé
parce que l'un de ses porte drapeau
était boxeur mohammed ali nom dans cette
secte qui pioche un petit peu dans
toutes les religions
on pense que les extraterrestres vont
venir sur la terre en est
vu les élus c'est certain d'entre vous
vous verrez pour les emmener dans leur
vaisseau spatial jusqu'à la fin des
temps donc là on est complètement dans
une attente messianique d'un discours
eschatologique un discours de la fin des
temps et donc on réinterprète on déforme
les faits uniquement dans ce sens enfin
faut pas oublier qu'à des gens qui
vivent dans la fiction et qui veulent
tout simplement se rendre intéressant
lorsque paraître complètement
condescendant de le dire comme ça mais
l'idée de détenir une vérité envers et
contre tous face à tonnerre important et
c'est toujours plus agréable que de
s'avouer qu'on ne comprend pas
définitivement rien à tous ces écrits
scientifiques
peut-être que là maintenant il est temps
de lister les raisons qui nous font
adhérer à cette théorie magique surtout
faut comprendre les conditions
auxquelles elles peuvent émerger ces
théories pour le terreau est donc ça
m'amène à parler de deux points qui sont
les deux façons de conclure cette
conférence première chose c'est la
question de la vulgarisation
on est bien placés là pour en parler si
on cherche des explications magique
fantastique
est-ce que c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas
compris la version scientifique
pire on n'y a pas accès en fait le
constat du succès les théories fumeuses
c'est à mon avis on pourra peut-être en
reparler après le constat de l'échec de
la vulgarisation
l'explication destiné au grand public
tous les livres tous les magazines les
expositions musées ray documentaire nous
parle réussi à contrer les partisans du
mystère tous les scientifiques dont j'ai
dit qu'ils consacré leur vie à partager
la vérité mais il la partage pas c'est
bien cette vérité en fait c'est pas
qu'ils nous cachent la vérité c'est tout
simplement qu'elle est englobé de jargon
qu'il faut avoir les codes pour la
comprendre les besoins constante par da
bunkérisation et sade les scientifiques
sont juste pas le temps de le faire il
faut le faire parce que le risque c'est
déjà en train de se produire
c'est que se crée un réseau parallèle
des connaissances et ça vous pouvez en
faire l'expérience très souvent en
discute avec des gens qui croient que
les z'omni on bâtit les pierres vite
beaucoup plus que on a pensé et qui vous
dit bah ouais mais tu l'a appris à la
fac comme s'il y avait une version
officielle celle des scientifiques
aveuglés par leurs préjugés terrés dans
leurs laboratoires et puis celle des
vrais savants qui sont les incompris
mais pionnier femmes comme ça qu'on me
les présente et kiliba qui défie les
idées reçues et qui représente en fait
l'éternel mythe de l'homme providentiel
du messie alors c'est bien beau mais si
trois pèlerins peuvent comprendre mieux
les choses et les milliers de
scientifiques surdiplômés qui
confondraient value échangent leurs
données en permanence se bat autant tout
arrêter maintenant et qui attendaient
l'arrivée des extraterrestres ce sera
beaucoup plus efficace il faut bien
comprendre que cette théorie elle
fonctionne période prospère pardon sur
une forme d'ignorance pas seulement les
ignorances des sociétés du passé qu'on
va combler petit à petit avec de
nouvelles fouilles archéologiques
elle se fonde à mon avis et je termine
là dessus sur notre incapacité à
imaginer des solutions techniques en
cette phrase n'est pas simple du tout la
rigolote notre incapacité à imaginer des
solutions techniques simples je
m'explique nous vivons dans une société
où la technologie est développée un
point jamais atteint dans les sens
d'humanité nous tout cela en partie
suivez bien les générations que nous
représentons nous sommes entourés d'un
machine de moteur et même maintenant des
logiciels capables de comprendre à notre
place de penser plutôt à la casse nous
devons apprendre à utiliser ces machines
on n'a pas besoin de savoir les
fabriquer est d'ailleurs aucun ingénieur
même le plus brillant des ingénieurs ne
connaît le fonctionnement de toutes les
machines qui existe est en fait on est
tellement assisté par
technologie qui nous paraît inconcevable
de lever une pierre sans grue ou de
déplacer quoi que ce soit d'un peu lourd
son camion à mais le truc c'est qu'il
faut bien se rendre compte que
l'humanité elle n'a pas attendu le
moteur diesel pour commencer à faire
quelque chose de ses dix doigts et donc
on doit se remettre dans les conditions
techniques les hommes du passé
conditions techniques ça vient quels
outils
vous avez hâte à l'époque et je vous
promets qu'elle est un de solutions
simples qui existent avec des cordes du
bois des systèmes de levier les systèmes
de contrepoint du temps que toujours
sous-estimé en archéologie expérimentale
et surtout qui nous fait sans doute le
plus défaut aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'ingéniosité
alors c'est sûr y'a des tas de
réalisation qui reste hors de portée aux
hommes durant l'antiquité mais avec les
quelques ingrédients que je vous donnais
il ya des choses incroyables qui sont
possibles et la preuve c'est qu'on les
trouve en fouillant alors c'est sûr ans
et moins sexy halle penser que ce sont
300 boonen qui ont levé les choeurs de
stonehenge pendant les journées entières
plutôt qu'une soucoupe volante mais ça
restera toujours plus stimulant
intellectuellement de comprendre comment
on fait nos ancêtres pour bar pour bâtir
toutes ces choses avec de simples cordes
et leur seul inventivité plutôt que
d'imaginer je ne sais quelle
intervention fantastique pour le faire à
leur place je remercie
[Applaudissements]